JAMIL MOLEDINA: I'm Jamil
Moledina from Google Play
business development leading
game strategic partnerships
as well as sourcing the
Android TV portfolio.
It's really great to
be back here at GDC
talking about we've been
working on on Android TV.
The platform brings together
the Android L operating system
and Google Play to
the living room,
where people spend five to six
hours per day per household.
Android TV helps you get
there because we already
have your community business
and product on Google Play.
Right now, smart
TVs are fragmented.
Since Android TV
is a platform, you
get to get there all at once.
Now at the same time,
we've designed the platform
to make it simple for you to
adapt your existing Android
game to Android TV
through a manifest update
and guidance on adapting the
design to the new form factor.
It's a bigger leap than
going from phone to tablet.
And at the same time
it's not the same--
it's not exactly the same.
You have to think about what
inputs are going to work.
You've made your game
for touch, but how
do you navigate in-game?
How do you scroll around
your game universe?
Also, can the game
scale visually?
Can the UI?
Here's Infinite Dreams'
"Sky Force 2014" on phones.
It's designed as a portrait
shoot 'em up-- you're
shooting up the screen.
And here's how it
adapted to television.
They went landscape,
added co-op multiplayer,
and of course gamepad
control support,
and adapted some
of the HUD as well.
Also, think about how
do your play sessions
scale to the living room?
Mobile games are made for
three to five minutes,
but how can you scale it to 15,
30, or maybe even two hours?
Our approach in putting together
the portfolio for Android TV
has been to select high
fidelity games that
are easily accessible, that
are scaled to the living room.
We've been curating everything
for the launch of the Nexus
player until now, in
much the same way that we
do featuring on the main store.
So it's the same
featuring process.
It's the same editorial
team that we're
using to curate
everything, and here you
can see how the
rails are organized.
This is how the
store presents itself
across all the devices that
Greg mentioned in his keynote.
And our mantra from the start
has been quality over quantity
in order to demonstrate
to developers,
OEM partners, and consumers
what the opportunity space is.
So we have over 80 40-star
or better games on the store
right now.
We focus on games that
have high visual fidelity
and high accessibility,
both in terms of controls
and content for a
broader audience.
And in terms of what
that content looks like,
we have great partners
supporting the store,
from indies to AAA developers.
Vector Unit's "Beach
Buggy Racing", who
we saw a lot of earlier today.
Disney's "Castle Delusions",
Senri's "Leo's Fortune",
Gameloft's "Despicable Me".
This is just a handful
of what we have.
But also, there's games
coming from console and PC,
like Ubisoft's "Valiant Hearts"
and "Oddworld-- Stranger's
Wrath", as well as indie hits
like "The Bridge" and "Goat
Simulator," making
it possible for you
to keep your living
room business model
consistent across platforms.
Now on the hardware side at
CES, Sony, Phillips, and Sharp
showed their smart TVs
running Android TV.
And Razer's Android
TV-powered Forge TV one
Best Gaming Product and
Consumer's Choice Award,
largely because it's an
all-purpose media and game
player for $100.
Now, I love this picture.
What is going to be the user
experience-- the unboxing
experience when people bring
home their TVs in 2015?
It's going to be the portfolio
that we're developing now.
That's why it's important
to adapt to Android TV now.
The games on there
are the first movers
that set the bar for applying
the app cultural shift
to living room games.
Also, there's going to be a lot
more product in the pipeline.
As the platform moves forward
and appears organically
on living room consumer
electronics devices,
the business case
becomes more apparent.
We'll be seeing more custom
experiences like "Sky Force
2014", and the experiences
Greg was talking about as well
with second screens.
And finally, here's this
classic game developer dream
that's possible-- it's
within reach-- to have
your game attached
to your player.
Have it live seamlessly between
phone, tablet, and living room
without constraint of
device or platform.
How do you get there?
The developer advocacy
team will help you sort
through the technical issues.
And the Google
Play [? BD ?] team
will help you get
on to the store.
Network to them through your
favorite social network,
and that's all I've got.
Thank you very much.